Speaker 1: Let's take some calls from people
in the audience.
We do this via discord at David Pakman dot
com slash discord.
As a reminder, if you are in the discord waiting
to talk to me, your nickname should be your
name and where you're calling from.
Anything else, including name only or nicknames
or usernames you are unfortunately going to
get skipped over.
The requirement for the format is name and
where you're calling from in some order.
In some order, like, for example, Jay from
New Jersey.
Let's go first to Jay from New Jersey.
Jay, welcome.
Speaker 5: Hey, David, how are you?
Question is.
Yes.
How do you justify eating meat, dairy and
eggs?
Speaker 1: Who do I have to justify to?
Speaker 5: Well.
When there's a victim involved, wouldn't you
have to justify it to them?
Speaker 1: I don't know.
Is that if you've perceived that there are
victims.
Every victim gets an explanation.
I don't even know what you're saying.
Speaker 5: Well, yeah.
So, like, if you if someone if you or someone
decides to eat meat, eggs.
Yeah.
And animals are dying for that decision.
Yeah, that's being made over and over again.
Do you feel like.
You could justify making that decision to
that victim who has to suffer and die for
it.
Speaker 1: Like, for example, when I have
my cappuccino, could I go to a cow and say.
Tell the cow why I'm drinking their milk,
for example.
Speaker 5: Yeah.
Like that cow who had to endure multiple pregnancies
and then be separated from their child.
And then, of course, as a child, as a male,
the males in the dairy industry almost always
will.
They always get separated on the first day
of life, and oftentimes they're killed on
the first or second day of life.
And this process will happen over and over
again to mother cows like several times until
they can no longer produce milk any longer,
and then they'll ultimately get sent to the
slaughterhouse.
So yeah, like in this scenario, like you're
painting like with the cappuccino.
Do you think that there is like a moral justification
for consuming animal products if it's not
a necessity, if we could just be using plant
based alternatives instead?
Speaker 1: So the problem I have with this
entire framing is that it's so absolutist
and narrow and it's not really like the way
the world actually works.
So, for example, sometimes you follow these
things to their logical conclusion.
Like, I read a lot about this and hopefully
you'll indulge me for a moment.
If we say, okay, eliminate all animal products
whatsoever.
Great.
So that now puts an incredible, incredible
strain on a handful of crops, which now need
to be grown in dramatically larger quantities
in order to replace all of those animal products.
This creates absolutely massive monoculture
farms, which are absolutely terrible for the
environment.
Many of these monocultures require absolutely
bonkers amounts of water in order to generate
equivalent amounts of, for example, protein.
The water use also leads to many, many animals
dying, everything from mice to, you know,
all sorts of other things.
And so we can do the entire thing that, I
gather, is what you would consider to be morally
right.
And then we would still end up killing so
many animals by virtue of how we restructure
and reorganize what humans eat.
Are we really better off by killing different
animals through drought and monoculture, etc.?
I mean, I don't know.
You tell me.
So how do you justify it to them?
Speaker 5: I would be interested in responding
to that counterpoint that you brought up,
but you did kind of not answer the question
I asked.
Speaker 1: The answer to my question is, I
don't know what I would tell a cow.
I've never spoken to a cow, so I don't know.
But what I'm telling you is it's the type
of question that's really just a black hole.
It doesn't really go anywhere in terms of
answering the broader questions about how
would we feed the planet on five monoculture
crops that would have to be exploded, you
know, 1,000,000% in order to replace all the
animal products.
You're not answering that question to me,
which is okay, too, what I'm telling you,
because your framing is arbitrarily narrow
and sort of myopic.
Speaker 5: Well, I. I can respond to that.
To that point, they ran up.
Okay.
But I do want to say that, you know, about
the meat, dairy and egg industry.
Like, it is like terribly, terribly cruel,
the standard practices of meat, dairy and
eggs.
Speaker 1: So, yeah, I'm with you right there.
I'm with you right there.
The standard practices are horrible.
What I do is, you know, I eat very little
red meat, for example.
And when I do, I try to know exactly what
farm is it coming from, where I could drive
and see what are the conditions.
I, you know, I think that like, for example,
the, you know, I'm on pasture free stuff where
I know exactly where it's coming.
You know, I'm doing certain things for myself.
But I agree with you.
The standard practices are terrible.
You and me, you and I are on the same page.
Speaker 5: Okay, cool.
Yeah.
And then just to touch on, like the the resource
intensive subject you brought up.
Yeah.
So actually, when you really look into the
amount of resources required that it takes
to.
Produce like raise livestock and breed these
animals and then raise them to slaughter weight
for me and then also for dairy and eggs.
When you look at how much water and crops
and resources are needed for all these different
kind of animal products, yes, it is just like
unbelievably intensive on the environment.
Speaker 1: And you're absolutely right.
You're absolutely.
Speaker 5: Right.
It's like if you've ever seen Cowspiracy like
they take that's a documentary for.
Speaker 1: Yeah I'm familiar with it Cowspiracy
you go inside and go Spirit Sea is fine, but
it's also lacking a lot of context and information.
What you also have to consider is if we replace
all of those products, what are they replaced
with to meet certain caloric needs?
It ends up being a very small number of things
that can do it, which generates monocultures
that's very bad for the environment in new
and other ways.
Jay, I got to run.
I've given you almost 10 minutes.
I know we're not going to agree.
Speaker 5: And there's one more I just want
to say, like, okay, about the amount of crops.
Like it's always less crops to eat a plant
based diet.
That's first of all.
So if you want to talk about crops, there'll
always be less crop related deaths on plant
based, plant based diet.
But you still have to answer the questions.
How do you justify eating meat, dairy and
eggs when there is a victim involved?
And you said.
Speaker 1: I'd have to think about how I talk
to the cow, Jay.
I'd have to.
I told you, I think that those questions are
philosophical.
Speaker 5: One of those like on the cows behalf,
the cows are dying for their decision.
Speaker 1: Jay No.
I've given you more time than I give anybody.
I got to let you go.
Okay?
Speaker 5: I will think about it.
David.
Thank you.
Speaker 1: Thank you.
Boy, see, this is why I tend when I saw the
user was j vegan.
I almost got away from it, but.
I do regret that.